also bei kräuter sollten mit augenmaß
mit mit einem verantwortungsgefühl
verbunden seien abgesehen von dem
aktuellen russland angriffs leer aber
dass ich gerade echt schwierig an der
diskussion also wir können nicht über
t-shirts aus bangladesch das genau
deswegen ich war gleichen maße über die
ukraine und die friedensbewegung ich
übrigens auch deswegen habe ich gesagt
wir bleiben am anfang
das muss doch es zu gestehen
[Musik]
13 fragen hier kommt die erste müssen
wir autokratien viel strenger
boykottieren wenn ihr sagt tendenziell
eher ja dann bitte auf dem grünen feld
platz nehmen oder positionieren und wenn
er sagt lieber nicht dann bitte auf dem
gelben fällt und mit
[Musik]
so vielen dank jetzt wissen wir wo ihr
steht große frage ist wo steht ihr
eigentlich autokraten soweit ich weiß
fast alles männer sind ja mehr oder
weniger alleinherrscher das heißt
meinungs- und pressefreiheit sowie
rechtsstaatlichkeit spielen wenn
überhaupt als fassade eine rolle
trotzdem machen wir lupenreinen super
demokraten natürlich gerne geschäfte mit
ihnen erstens wegen des geldes zweitens
wegen des geldes und drittens aus einer
ernsthaften politischen überzeugung
heraus dass nämlich wandel entstehen
kann durch handeln das beispiel russland
hat gezeigt das stimmt so nicht immer im
gegenteil haben wir jetzt die härtesten
sanktionen aller zeiten wie rekrutieren
quasi alles oft das bisschen öl und gas
jeden tag für mehrere hundert millionen
euro aber auch das wird ja diskutiert
gerade das heißt wir müssen uns ganz
generell fragen wie wollen wir zukünftig
mit derlei staaten umgehen also mit
katar mit china mit der türkei die einen
sagen jetzt ist die zeit für eine
zeitenwende wir müssen radikal umdenken
und viel strenger und viel härter
boykottieren am besten alle autokratien
auf der welt die anderen sagen so
einfach ist es nicht wir müssen auch
weiter in wirtschaftsbeziehungen bleiben
damit die zarte pflanze demokratie
vielleicht am ende sogar noch eine
chance hat wir werden bei dieser folge
keine finale antwort finden aber
vielleicht so eine art faustregel so
eine grobe orientierung linie wer weiß
vielleicht finden diese beiden parteien
am ende auch einen kompromiss wir werden
sie jetzt erstmal die frage an euch wo
würdet ihr euch positionieren ganz
spontan grün viel strenger boykottieren
oder gelb lieber weiter in
wirtschaftsbeziehungen bleiben schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare so die
spielregeln sind ganz einfach wenn ihr
der gegenseite in irgendeinem punkt
zustimmt dann könnt ihr auf sie zugehen
in dem ihr einen schritt nach vorne
macht wenn er sagt grundsätzlich finde
ich das gar nicht so schlecht was du
sagst aber das ist wirklich bullshit
dann könnt ihr auch einen schritt
zurückgehen mein ziel wäre euch am ende
der folge hier vorne alle in eine art
kompromiss hält zu versammeln in der
hoffnung dass wir irgendwie eine linie
finden wo wir uns einig werden und ich
weiß bei diesem thema müssen wir an
jeder stelle immer wieder neu
differenzieren könnte auch gerne hin und
her laufen wie es euch beliebt die große
frage die wir natürlich heute haben ist
auf der einen seite eine allgemeine
faustregel wie umgehen mit autokratien
im allgemeinen und natürlich starten wir
aber erstmal mit dem konkreten wir haben
gerade einen russischen angriffskrieg
da ist ja die sachlage vielleicht noch
ein bisschen anders frage nummer 2 und
die geht an arthur du hast familie und
freunde in der ukraine du hast da viele
bande ich glaube sogar eine freundin ist
ukrainisch wie gehst du aktuell mal ganz
allgemein gesagt mit russland boykotten
um sagst du oder muss man da schon
differenzieren nun sagen wir es mal so
all-in hätte man aus meiner perspektive
von anfang an machen müssen die progress
die problematik aber eher warum ich
jetzt hier bin in dieser position dass
wir nicht alle autokratischen regime
durch den durch die bank weg
boykottieren können wenn wir jetzt alle
autokratien boykottieren und noch viel
konsequenter als ich es gerade tun dann
entstand ist das könnte das problem
entstehen berg blockbildung das bedeutet
dass bestimmte autokratische staaten
sich zusammenschließen und ein
gegengewicht zu unseren westlichen
demokratischen grundordnung bilden das
dass die problematik dahinter und warum
ist das bei russland anders es ist ein
angriffskrieg ist das ein radikaler
angriffskrieg er ist schon nicht seit
heute da die eskalation gab es schon am
donnerstag kann man revolution und jetzt
ist sozusagen das fass zum überlaufen
und hätte man deiner meinung nach schon
vor acht jahren sagen wissen wir müssen
viel härter sanktionieren ja natürlich
man hätte sagen sollen man hätte es tun
sollen das problem ist bei der ganzen
debatte dass deutschland aus meiner
perspektive nicht klug gehandelt hat
also meine meinung ist dass man bei
boykotten klug handeln sollte und wissen
mit wem man redet und wie man redet
katja was glaubst du haben wir gerade
behandeln wir gerade klug in russland
ukraine krieg verhandeln viel zu langsam
gehandelt viel zu schwach wir handeln
inkonsequent und vor allem sind wir als
deutsche personal solche
staatsangehörige müssten wir auch fehler
einräumt fehler der vergangenheit die
dahingehend auch passiert sind und das
richtet sich natürlich auch an unsere
wirtschaftlichen interessen wie wir
weiterhin und trotz vieler warnungen
seit vielen vielen jahren mit russland
geführt haben über die nord stream
projekt aber natürlich auch über viele
viele andere wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen haben wir das was heute in
der ukraine passiert auch möglich
gemacht wir sollten autokratien auf
jeden fall boykottieren weil die für
unzählige menschenrechtsverletzungen
verantwortlich sind in wiesen nicht
plakatieren dann lassen wir ihnen freie
hand das zu tun was wir wollen und das
kann nicht in unserem interesse sein
jetzt ist es ja vollkommen eindeutig in
bei dieser sache das als die größten und
die wesentlichen opfer des krieges und
die menschen in der ukraine
andererseits sagen viele auch naja jetzt
haben wir diese heftigen boykotte auch
die russische bevölkerung die
unbeteiligte bevölkerung ist davon
betroffen also wäre geldautomaten
wirtschaftsboykott betreffen auch die
menschen der rubel ist fast nichts mehr
wert und so weiter wie bewertest du das
ist das ein kollateralschaden die man
hinnehmen muss also ich möchte erstmal
sagen dass kein einziges schicksal
gerade mit dem zu vergleichen das was im
training passiert mario pohl ist
komplett vernichtet es ist ein
vernichtungskrieg mit dem russischen
imperialistischen ziel die ukraine für
immer von der landkarte zu löschen das
bedeutet auch unser komforth hier in
deutschland ist nicht mit dem zu
vergleichen was zu vergleichen was
gerade in der ukraine passiert das ist
das erste das zweite ist was die
bevölkerung angeht auch da muss man
natürlich differenzieren auch da muss
man natürlich schauen wen trifft was
aber letztlich seien wir noch mal ganz
ehrlich müssen wir gerade alles tun um
die ukraine zu verteidigen geht ihr auf
sie zu stimmt ihr zu
verzögert so ein bisschen warum ja weil
ich dieses argument mit der
zivilbevölkerung die jetzt auch
geschädigt wird wirklich mir ein
bisschen zu herzen nehme wenn ich höre
dass zum beispiel mcdonald's in russland
mehrere zehntausend zulieferer hart
bauern die jetzt eben keine abnehmer
mehr haben dann frag mich so in schon
inwiefern diese maßnahme hilft wenn man
sich aus muss man jetzt zurückzieht
waren auch inwiefern sie dazu beiträgt
wirklich den ukraine konflikt zu lösen
weil sie nicht eine staatsnahe branche
ist unter der obhut indirekt leidet wenn
sie verschwindet oder putin
wahrscheinlich auch kein interesse
persönlichen picknicks hat das heißt da
frage ich mich schon ob wir dabei dieses
auch nicht am ziel vorbei schießen und
nicht menschen der möglichkeit berauben
eine menschenwürdige existenz zu führen
weil wir einfach quasi mit kanonen auf
spatzen schießen und ich bin für
sanktionen aber dort wo sie dem regime
weh tun und nicht dort wo sie in erster
linie der zivilbevölkerung schauten ich
bin überzeugt dass wandel in autokratien
primär durch austausch entsteht und
nicht durch boykott denkmal nordkorea
das am stärksten abgeschottete land der
welt wie geht es den leuten wird sie
hungern sie leben unter missraten
umständen eine ein aufstand gegen kimi
um ihn ist nicht in sicht so viel ich
weiß von daher denke ich wenn schon
wandel durch handel und ohne handel
garantiert kein wunder bestimmte
portable
das heißt so würde es sagen mcdonald's
porto brauchen wir nicht unbedingt also
meine position ist ja eigentlich eher
dass wenn schon bei kontern immer bei
katja also die unterscheidung oder auch
die etwas heuchlerisch unterscheidung
zwischen wo wird boykottiert wird nicht
blockiert hängt ja sehr davon ab wo wir
gerade hinschauen ja also wenn wir jetzt
sozusagen russland boykottieren und das
gas von saudi arabien zu bekommen tausch
de facto ein diktator durch einen
anderen oder ein totalitäres regime
durch ein anderes wir haben nur leider
sehr viele autoritäre regime auf der
erde saudi arabien china und viele
andere mehr wenn wir die alle aus den
handelsbeziehungen rausnehmen dann wäre
die welt eine andere aber prinzipiell
sollten demokratien es verhindern
vermeiden mit regimen die autoritär sind
totalitär sind und zu mal solchen die
kriege führen handelsbeziehung zu
treiben aber ich bin natürlich auch der
meinung dass wenn man über boykotte
spricht dann geht man eher davon aus
dass man über den bankrott einen anderen
diktator oder tyrannen oder was auch
immer autoritären führer zu irgendwas
zwingend aber natürlich nicht die
zivilbevölkerung ja das ist ja immer die
schmale gratwanderung also das jetzt
russische kinder kein playmobil haben
das finde ich auch einfach und schön ja
und dann trifft es einfach immer die
falschen und genau diese differenzen
wollen wir hier ja ausdifferenzieren
absolut darum geht es ja und melina
durchschüttelt so ein bisschen mit dem
kopf herum ja also bei manchen sachen
dachte ich mir ja da gehe ich voll mit
bei anderen sachen dachte ich mir oh
mein gott habe ich versuch's mal so
zusammenzufassen also ich bin auch
absolut der meinung dass das konsequent
sein soll und wenn wir sagen wir sollten
alle autokratischen regimes oder von mir
aus auch alle regime an die
menschenrechtsverletzungen krasse
menschenrechtsverletzung machen sollten
wir boykottieren da stimme ich voll zu
das einzige wo ich mir denke so
russische kinder hamas kein playmobil
ich weiß das war nur so ein beispiel
aber ich mein ich hatte als kind nicht
mal
eltern ich hatte nichts ich hab's nicht
eine haut erfahren was passiert wenn man
autokratische regime nicht boykottiert
und ihnen nichts entgegensetzt denn ich
bin aus bosnien ich musste von dort
fliehen wegen dem gerne zieht der das
passierte vier jahre lang
konzentrationslager vernichtungslager
vergewaltigungs lager die längste
belagerung einer halb hauptstadt in der
modernen welt geschichte all das ist bei
uns passiert vier jahre lang alle
wussten es und niemand hat etwas getan
und deshalb sehe ich es als meine
pflicht jetzt zu helfen wenn menschen
weltweit das gleiche oder ähnliches
durchmachen müssen weil ich weiss der
größte schmerz ist zuwenden jemand
überhaupt versucht zu helfen denn es ist
es jetzt die richtige also wir haben es
gerade sie sagt mcdonald's boykottieren
ist der falsche weg trifft trifft er die
falschen und eben nicht das regime werde
ich dich richtig verstanden sagst du
näher kommen leute jetzt in letzterer
einmal konsequent durchziehen trifft
vielleicht auch ein bisschen die
falschen aber das nennt man dann hin was
sagst du vielleicht vorher würde ich vor
kurz erklären warum ich mich eher auf
dieser seite positioniert habe das hat
das hat mit der arzt zu tun wie er die
frage formuliert habt um mit zwei
begriffen dass eine ist auto kräftig
autokratisches regime das eben auch ein
bisschen so sagen immer synonym
verhandelt wurde eine autokratie das ist
eine autokratie das ist eine diktatur
was ist ein totalitäres regime das ist
nicht nur eine politikwissenschaftliche
unterscheidung das ist sozusagen auch
der auch für strategien auch für
politische strategien gemacht dass ein
unterschied ob man das mit einem land
sagen wenn man mit der türkei zu tun hat
oder auch venezuela
autokratische regime die aber ihre
legitimität daraus beziehen dass sie
ausgewählt worden zu sagen die deswegen
den schrein von institutionen die an der
kritischen öffentlichkeit wie einer
unabhängigen gerichtsbarkeit und so
weiter aufrecht erhalten wo es auch
gewisse räume gibt auch für opposition
auch wenn das immer sagen an der beko
herrschaft unterworfen ist oder eine
diktatur wie china das ist das ist nicht
das was man das ist ein unterschied und
ich glaube russland ist gerade dabei von
dem einen zum anderen zu kippen wenn wir
alle auto grad wir schwimmen in der welt
profitieren dann würden natürlich in
einer welt leben die sehr isoliert er
ist und was das praktisch nicht möglich
dass auch das schießen wir wieder auf
grenzen das heißt es ist form von
zusammenarbeit sind notwendig zum
beispiel ein land das ich sehr gut kenne
aus dem ich auch in dem ich auch als
reporter gearbeitet habe nämlich die
türkei
die türkei besteht ja nicht nur aus dem
regime erdogan sondern einen teil der
gesellschaft um die 50 prozent oder so
dieses regierung ablehnen und und ich
glaube dass er tore schießen das wird
nicht für alle zeiten existieren und die
frage wo sich die ich hin wohin sich die
türkei wohin sich die türkische
gesellschaft richten wird diese frage
entscheidet sich schon heute und der
westen steht vor der schwierigen aufgabe
und europa steht vor der schwierigen
aufgabe partner zu bleiben ohne sich zu
komplizen dieses regimes zu machen
leicht gesagt schwer getan aber genau
das ist die aufgabe hättest du gefragt
sollte man daher herangehen ich werde
dich hätte ich mich auf der seite
positioniert weil ich es auch falsch
wenn er zum beispiel im umgang mit der
türkei
bin ich ich bin nicht für
wirtschaftssanktionen das ist auch das
was türkische oppositionelle immer
wieder sagen sie sind nicht dagegen wenn
siemens oder daimler und so weiter in
der türkei
investieren davon profitiert man ja auch
das bringt ja auch jobs was die immer
wieder sagen die sonne hat auch
verantwortung übernehmen und sich nicht
zu komplizen machen deswegen bei dem er
die formulierung hatte ist ein anderes
wort benutzt als votieren sie sich nicht
dahin gestellt und jetzt komme ich zu
russland und dann auch zum ende russland
ist ein anderer punkt das wurde eben
schon gesagt ist es an es wird ein
angriffskrieg geführt und warum warum
ist dann bot die richtige maßnahme und
tag gibt es glaube ich nicht darum dass
wir jetzt und sein gewissen bereinigen
also dieses bei allem respekt aber
dieses protestantischen gewissens ding
das ist nicht meins das ziel des
boykotts ist nicht weniger als der
rechen change es geht darum dieses
system dieses regime auf allen ebenen
auf einer symbolischen also kultur in
der kultur in sport und so weiter zu
ächten wie südafrika seinerzeit aber
auch in mit allen anderen mitteln auch
mit wirtschaftlichen mitteln natürlich
auch mit konsequenzen für die
bevölkerung die hässlich sind dann darf
man sich auch nichts vormachen aber das
ziel des ganzen ist genauso wie es joe
biden und das findet passiert auch nicht
so oft hast du schon bald zustimmen aber
er hat recht das ziel ist dass version
change weil russland hat mit diesem
angriffskrieg eine grenze überschritten
hinter dies auch kein zurück geben kann
ich weiß nicht wie man sich das in der
bundesregierung vorstellt nach meinem
dafürhalten kann man mit putin selbst
wenn dieser kriegt man diese
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine am ende
scheitern sollte was wir glaube ich alle
sehr offen wird man mit russland nicht
einfach so weitermachen können und das
heißt du sagst wirtschaftsboykott du
sagst sport boykott du sagst
kulturbeutel hier werden wir über
russland reden wenn wir war ausland im
ausland er ist davon nicht überzeugt
warum nicht hier habe ich gerade gesagt
ich würde
eigentlich auch wirklich sehr viel und
zu kosten drücken gesorgt das verwischen
sich die grenzen aber der punkt den du
erwähnst unternehmen sollen zum beispiel
eiben in der türkei ob verantwortung
übernehmen genau in diese richtung haben
wir uns in den letzten jahren entwickelt
wir haben die globalisierung und den
internationalen handel gestartet ohne
rücksicht auf menschenrechte wir sind
dorthin gegangen wo die ware und die
menschen am wenigsten waren und ebenso
in den letzten jahren ist bewusstsein
entstanden hey moment vielleicht haben
ja unsere westlichen unternehmen an
verantwortung entlang ihrer lieferkette
und können sich in ihren exotischen
tochtergesellschaften nicht total
daneben benehmen inzwischen haben ihre
lieferketten gesetzen deutschland das
heißt sie haben jetzt mechanismen mit
denen wir unternehmen zur rechenschaft
ziehen können für missstände entlang der
produktionskette
und das heißt es ist nicht mehr einfach
so
voneinander getrennt so strikt
voneinander getrennt wir haben
inzwischen eine eine ein kultur bis
jetzt noch nicht wahnsinnig etablierten
die rechtsprechung muss auch noch folgen
aber wir haben da jetzt harte
maßnahmen ergriffen und globalisierung
in ethisch geordnete bahnen zu lenken
und dieses ganze radikal boykottieren
neben wirtschaftsbeziehungen karten
läuft dem zuwider und es ist für mich in
dieser hin ein rückschließen viele leute
und zwar nicht in ihre konsumenten rolle
die konsumenten rolle ist mir ziemlich
egal ob jetzt playmobil oder big mac
oder billy regal nicht in der
konsumenten rolle ist und in der rolle
aus arbeitnehmer zulieferer etc wirklich
wirklich schädigt wir waren gerade eben
relativ weit vorn ihr seid ihr alle ja
ich sagen wir mit melina anderen kommt
katja burkhard java schuldigen
dass ich muss sagen zieles von deiner
argumentation gehe ich auch tatsächlich
sehr mit alles was angeht
wirtschaftliche beziehungen und dass die
vermeintlich irgendwas diplomatisch
bringe ich muss sagen aus persönlicher
erfahrung aber eben auch aus ganz ganz
vielen politischen diskussionen daraus
dass ich vor ort war ich war fortan
kasachstan hat dort mit
menschenrechtsaktivistinnen gesprochen
meine familie kommt dass belarus hier
freunde aus der ukraine wandel durch
handel hatte überhaupt gar nichts
gebracht weil das ganze im prinzip nur
den status quo weiter erhält und der
status quo bedeutet dir finanzieren
weiter diese regime und man darf sich
nichts vormachen
man darf sich nichts vormachen dass
dieses geld irgendwie an die russischen
bevölkerung weiter geht das sind
organischen strukturen gerade die sich
dort vernetzt haben von denen wir auch
wirtschaftlich hier profitieren muss ich
auch wirklich ganz ehrlich sagen was
gazprom angeht was lobbyismus angeht ist
dass wir hier davon profitiert haben
dass es nummer eins und das andere ist
ich würde mal gerne davon loskommen dass
wir die russische bevölkerung von ihrer
verantwortung freisprechen
weil da gibt es einen deutsch am
mehrheit die putin und die diesen
angriffskrieg unterstützt es sind
riesengroß das sind stadien voll gewesen
jetzt mit putin anhängern das sind
diejenigen wirklich die das ist total
schwer zu beschreiben das ist im prinzip
eine sekte und einen einzigen menschen
schon aus dieser propaganda maschinerie
rausbringen es unfassbar schwierig und
natürlich ist nicht nur ein
wirtschaftlicher wallcott das einzige
das andere ist zivilgesellschaft zu
fördern es ist freie medien zu fördern
es ist vor ort des kulturellen
austauschs letztlich auch zu fördern ist
es präventiv getan werden kann aber
jetzt gerade sind wir in einem
historischen epochalen umbruch und da
finde ich meiner meinung nach muss alles
auf dem tisch liegen alles wo vorher
gesagt von ist nein wissen wir nicht
trauen wir uns nicht unbedingt ran wir
wollen jetzt mal schauen wir wollen den
diplomatischen kurs gehen die apps mit
politik ist gescheitert so und das ist
mein status quo ich sagen wir müssen
über alles reden wir müssen über alles
reden und zwar von a bis z und da darf
es keine verbote mehr geben wir müssen
auf jeder erdenklichen ebene versuchen
diesen grausamen krieg zu stoppen also
hab ich überhaupt keinen widerspruch
also ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig
werden muss uns sagen so abstrakt über
gleichermaßen über den iran china wir
reden jetzt über zahlen reden jetzt nur
über russland würde ich jetzt so gerne
rüberspringen so das habe ich überhaupt
kann
du hast hin und hergelaufen erkennbar
sein was heißt da erst dann wieder daher
fast militanter auf dem vulkanring kasse
das problem an der ganzen geschichte ist
ich stimme katja in fast allen punkten
zu aber gleichzeitig gibt es ja auch der
diese facette dass wir in gewisser weise
in russland soll nach dem zusammenbruch
des kreativen unseren ding hatten wir
hatten sonst nullpunkt in
anführungszeichen nicht wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gibt es gibt keine lebens gab
keine lebensmittel keine babynahrung
teilweise und dann kam der handel dann
kam sozusagen dieses neo kapitalistische
innerhalb dieses russischen systems und
dieses wandel durch handel hat uns im
endeffekt auch gleichzeitig ein
instrument gegebenen zusagen russland
wieder zurück in diese 90ern diese
wilden 90er zurück zu sanktionieren was
du was sehr sehr tief in diesem
kollektiven würden wieder wahrscheinlich
selbst weiß unterbewusstsein vorhanden
ist also die neunziger die wilden
neunziger wir hatten gar nichts und
meine hoffnung dass im endeffekt durch
diese wilden 90er umdenken selbst der
putin treuen zu bewirken ulrike enormer
zu dieser diskussion ja das erste ist
handelskrieg ist auch krieg punkt ja
gesehen bin ich so der sublimieren aber
wenn wir da hier die billige t shirts
kaufen und so weiter in bangladesch
sterben auch kinder ja oder stürzen die
gebäude ein und das sehen wir halt nicht
weil die nicht jeden abend im fernsehen
sind im zdf und weil wir so nicht sehen
wollen weil wir das schöne t shirt
wollen ja aber handelskrieg sagt man in
der soziologie ist auch krieg und das zu
verstehen was mal das erste ja das
zweite ist bei dennis anzusetzen regime
change ja da habe ich ein kleines
problem mit als wir die apartheid
gemacht haben haben wir kein regime
change gemacht sondern wir haben gesagt
wir machen keine handel mit südafrika
und deswegen sozusagen werden wir die
irgendwie so austrocknen dass die ihre
change das ist ja was anderes ja dass
wir sagen nein wir machen kein handel
also du setzt beim verhalten setzt du
bei dir an aber du hast nicht den
moralischen impetus zu sagen wir change
sein regime
so war das nicht gemeint man mag so sein
aber so wurde es gesagt hin zu werden
aber ich freu mich schon seit ich das
mit dem moralischen recht das ist ja
aber das kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen
crimes against humanity
im deutschen mit dem schönen euphemismus
grad und verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit übersetzt eigentlich
verbrechen gegen die menschheit das ist
ja nach dem nationalsozialismus und den
zweiten weltkrieg ist das ja ein solches
recht etabliert worden und es gab auch
vor auch gut begründete militärische
intervention das dass das auch nicht
besonders demokratische vietnam
kambodscha einmarschiert ist und das
morden der roten khmer oder verändern
und zwar völkerrechtlich auch nicht
sauber trotzdem war das saubere wasser
das an der wand über das richtige also
es war ja nicht der das problem beim
irak-krieg glaube ich war ein anderes
ich will nur ganz kurz mit interesse
werden das wäre ein bisschen versuchen
zu uns zu sortieren werden wir noch mal
ganz kurz beim fußball bleiben können
danach gehen wir aufs große ganze und
gehen nochmal auch über lieferketten und
strategien und welthandel insgesamt ich
wollte nur noch mal genau diesen punkt
aufgreifen jetzt die frage nach regime
change also wenn er aus dem inneren
kommen soll also wenn die wenn die
bevölkerung quasi in die lage versetzt
werden kann einen regime change schäden
zu bekommen glaubst du katja das
bankrotte dabei helfen weil vielleicht
die not größer essen die leute dann
sagen jetzt reicht's wir brauchen jetzt
hier neun oben glaubst du das hilft
wirst deine erfahrung auch aus belarus
zum beispiel was ich muss erstmal möchte
ich auch dann gegen belarus ist auch ein
eigenständiges land was in russland zu
trennen ist die bayerische bevölkerung
hat 2020 mit der belarussischen
gewaltfreien revolution gezeigt sie sind
gegen diese diktatur sie haben wirklich
alles in ihrer macht stehende getan um
zu zeigen dass sie diese demokratie so
schnell wie möglich eigentlich aus
deiner russ raus
diese diktatur so schnell wie möglich
aus belarus raus haben wollen und dass
man beispielsweise solche momente in
bestimmten konflikten wo dann eben auch
genau solche walcott und genau solche
sanktionen aus dem westen eben hätten
helfen können zum richtigen zeitpunkt
den richtigen leuten eben zu helfen das
sind da die beiden russinnen die gesagt
haben sagen zu nähe dieses regime weil
nichts ist schlimmer der leidensdruck
ist so groß wenn du nicht gesehen wirst
wenn du das gefühl hast du bist den
ländern die es wirtschaftlich eigentlich
könnten wir zu helfen dass du den
einfach absolut egal wessen deswegen
glaube ich ist es fatal zu denken dass
ausschließlich einen boykott der absatz
in dem umdenken statt also so zu einem
umdenken führen wird und gleichzeitig
ist ihr aber der wandel das dort
bestimmte produkte nicht mehr verfügbar
sind dass dort bestimmte apps nicht mehr
zugänglich sind et cetera sind ja für
viele erst mal ein anzeichen ok es
ändert sich überhaupt irgendwas weil
ansonsten würden wir wahrscheinlich
einfach weiter in ihrem quasi daily life
drin sein würden weiter einfach ihren
tagesgeschehen nachgehen und könnten
sich somit mit dem status quo einfach
abfinden aber es geht mir vor allem
darum dass wir aufhören die ganze zeit
nur über russland zu reden weil es geht
darum über die ukraine und mit den
ukrainerinnen zu reden weil diejenigen
werden gerade hier in deutschland
boykottiert von der friedensbewegung die
friedensbewegung sagt wir wollen um
gottes willen keine waffen und dies und
das und jenes ukrainerinnen werden
ausgeladen von demo selensky durfte auf
der friedensdemo jetzt durfte in seinem
video nicht gezeigt werden andrej melik
der ukrainische botschafter wurde
eingeladen zu einem konzert wohl nur
russische künstler entstehen also
entschuldigt bitte aber hört doch mal
den betroffenen zu dort ja ja ich denke
nur dass meine position also wirklich
ganz klar ist dass sanktionen und
boykotte dort wo sie direkt das regime
treffen in staatsnahen branchen- und den
in branchen die direkt güter herstellen
oder aktuelle güter die in den krieg
einfließen absolut und nochmals zum
wandel durch handel wir haben zuerst
einfach handel betrieben und
globalisierung aufgebauter raubtierkäfig
alles ohne anspruch auf wandel und das
hat sich aber in den letzten jahren
geändert wir haben nun den anspruch auf
einem wandel durch den handel und diese
zarte pflanze auch wenn sie erst spät
gekommen ist die möchte ich nicht so
vorschnell zerstören und ich finde wir
haben auch eine verantwortung haben
nämlich auch abhängigkeiten geschaffen
die leute in bangladesch die hängen
davon ab dass wir die t shirts kaufen
würden wir sie besser für 50 euro pro
stück kaufen aus fünf euro pro stück
aber wir können die leute nicht zuerst
in die abhängigkeit führen und sagen
andere sagen es war gekommen und wir
haben immer die ressourcen und
anderweitig zu versorgen aber für diese
länder das ist nicht alles schien alles
nicht gekannten ist es nicht so einfach
dann neue lieferketten aufzustellen und
neue wirtschaftsmodell aufzubauen wir
haben unser gewissen sehr schnell damit
beruhigt aber wir haben macht und wir
haben verantwortung wir haben diese
prämie mitverursacht durch unsere
neoliberale globalisierung
und jetzt ist derzeit das zu ändern
haben nicht durch die globalisierung
das heißt du plädiert dafür
nicht beantwortet also boykotte sollten
mit augenmaß mit mit einem
verantwortungsgefühl verbunden sein
abgesehen von dem aktuellen russland
angriff wäre das nicht gerade echt
schwierig an der diskussion also wir
können nicht über t-shirts aus
bangladesch ist genau deswegen ich war
ganz erreichen maße über die ukraine und
die friedensbewegung und das schön dass
du da natürlich nein das ist doch das
ist auch ich das ist das ist also das
ist uns ein problem der fragestellung
reden wir über russland reden wir über
das und ich viel unterstützung in der zu
dir und komme nicht jedes und ich habe
das jetzt auf die letzten tage ein paar
mal geschrieben an verschiedenen stellen
über diese blau-gelbe deutsche
heimlichkeit so habe ich das genannt wo
die ukraine nur stören weil die deutsche
ukraine solidarität die könnte so schön
sein und so heimelig sein wenn nicht
immer diese komischen ukraine dazwischen
grätschen würden und weil wir jetzt
gerade dabei sind wollte ich jetzt
einfach mal zu dir kommen weil das ist
jetzt einfach ein anderer ich bin das
schwierig das auf einem nenner zu
diskutieren über t-shirts und
lieferketten aus bangladesch ich
übrigens auch deswegen habe ich gesagt
wir bleiben am anfang bei russland und
gehen danach
das machen was machst du das zugestimmt
haben also wir reden sehr sehr viel
darüber dass einfache menschen in
autoritären staaten leiden aber das ding
ist zu dem zeitpunkt wo die anfangs zu
leiden zu dem zeitpunkt wo die welt
etwas merkt wo die welt genug hat von
dem scheiß und einschreitet zu dem
zeitpunkt haben die menschen gegen das
gegen die sich dieses system richtet
schon extrem viel mehr geritten wir sind
vielleicht tot alle vielleicht wenn sie
gefolgt hat zwangs geschwängert
zwangssterilisiert alles möglich also
erstmal das sollte der fokus sein
zweitens denn wir wirklich so herzblut
und dieses
wort ist in gut
tragen
wir können aber
auf jeden fall zweitens wenn wir also
ich bin ja auch nicht herzlos wenn wir
wirklich an die menschen denken die in
diesen autoritären regime von diesen
autoritären regimen leiden das ding ist
ihr später wir eingreifen desto mehr
leiden sie weil ich habe es ja selbst
mit bosnien gesehen ich wollte zehn
jahre lang nicht einlenken hat comscore
angegriffen slowenien angegriffen
kroatien angriffen bosnien angriffen
vier jahre lang inklusive keller zieht
denn weder kosovo angegriffen und er
musste nachdem er druck ignoriert hat
dann nachdem er sektion ignoriert
nachdem er alles mögliche ignoriert hat
musste er weg geräumt werden das war für
die menschen in serbien viel größeres
leid als dass die sanktionen hatten
welche ihnen ehrlich gesagt nicht viel
übrig haben weil du bist libyen sowie so
einen scheiß land wo es nichts zu kaufen
gab also wenn man nicht früh genug an
schreitet mit dem argument die einfachen
menschen werden leiden dann werden die
einfachen menschen am ende sterben und
das haben wir auch in deutschland
gesehen dass nazi-deutschland weggebombt
werden musste weil davor eine empires
mensch politik herstellen ganz vielen
wählern nicht überall wirklich weise
aber in ganz vielen ecken und ländern
war so hitler tut ja uns nicht sein
warum sollten wir jetzt gegen
deutschland kämpfen ich glaube man kann
jetzt verstehen konflikte schon ein
bisschen differenziert betrachten aber
ich es verstehe deinen punkt absolut der
ist genau die entscheidende frage jetzt
geht ja der konflikt aus russland wird
jetzt weiter getragen wir wollen
unabhängiger werden von öl und gas das
weiß der vizekanzler nach katar und geht
von dem einen dilemma zum dilemma muss
von dem einen autokraten sind oder von
einem diktator zum nächsten gehen also
was heißt das jetzt was du gerade gesagt
hast wenn du das jetzt in münster heißt
dass kein gas aus katar ist menschen
rechtsmäßig auch mindestens fragwürdig
und bei qatar ist grob dass bei katar
und gerade weil katar ist das problem
nicht nur
die menschen also die menschenrechtslage
in katar selber da ist katar nicht mal
das schlimmste land in der region dass
katar ist eine der
mythologischen überschuss bei den in
afghanistan in syrien also katar ist
eine der
global exporteure islamismus wenn das
heißt also viel das ist viel
dramatischer als nur die
menschenrechtslage und das hat doch die
genau die frage die wir uns jetzt
stellen muss und was bedeutet das jetzt
also wenn wir das irgendwie eine
orientierungs dinge suchen heißt dass
wir dürfen jetzt gas kaufen von denen
oder nicht da hab ich mal sagen ja also
zu den schlimmsten sowjetzeiten wir
wollen nicht behaupten dass die
sowjetunion irgendeine form von diktator
aber zu den schlimmsten zeiten ist das
gas immer geschlossen ja wir haben 1981
habe die sowjetunion die olympischen
spiele boykottiert weil es einen heißen
krieg in afghanistan war ja und auch da
ist die frage nicht thematisiert worden
ja ich bin für eine eurasische
friedensordnung würden nur gerne darauf
hinweisen dass wir jetzt fracking öl
machen in amerika machen wir krieg gegen
die natur ja und insofern sind natürlich
die option tatsächlich eigentlich
weniger ja wenn wir nicht nach ihr katar
wollen nicht nach irak wollen saudi
arabien oder fracking dann ist wir
müssen wir gucken wie kriegen wir die
ukraine jetzt erstmal unmittelbar
besteht ja was sind die lösung zwar
morgen in zwei wochen in wie auch immer
sofort ja dass das leid aufhört bin ich
sofort dabei der frage nach der ukraine
gibt es auch überhaupt gar kein vertun
das ist vollkommen eindeutig das ist
auch klar aber ich würde trotzdem gerne
sind die grautöne auslud vielleicht
kriegen wir ein kriterium aber wann man
ab welchem grad der
menschenrechtsverletzung oder der kriegs
einwirkung aber wann man sagt da ist ein
boykott gerechtfertigt da er nicht wo
ist das augenmaß so jetzt die frage an
euch ist das vorgehen des vize-kanzlers
mit dem fall richtig oder wäre es
richtiger zu sagen wir boykottieren
natürlich diesen staat auch weil wir
haben jetzt gelernt wir wollen eben
nicht mehr diese abhängigkeiten haben
was würdet ihr sagen angenommen ihr wert
kanzlerin oder kanzler ich sage genau
das was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe wir
haben das zu lange hochhalten kosten und
letzte stecken wir mitten in der scheiße
und wir müssen jetzt weil es ohne
möglich ist alle alle alle autoritären
regime komplett zu boykottieren jetzt
müssen die abstufungen machen und jetzt
müssen wir gucken okay das ist so ein
scheiß regime es ist auf einer skala von
1 bis 10 vielleicht sieben scheiße
deshalb machen wir vielleicht sehen
wollt so interessant genau das ist ja
die frage also dass
oder eine fußball-wm bd die könnte man
ja relativ harmlos und boykottiert und
also ich finde dass man wichtige
marke kratzer genau ist es unfassbar
vor allem jetzt olympia spiele in china
china ist das paradebeispiel also
jahrzehntelang wurde ignoriert was sie
ihren eigenen hand chinesischen
dissidenten antun was tibetern antun was
die uiguren an schon seit jahrzehnten
und treysa uns soweit genau und jetzt
sind wir in einer situation in der szene
zu der welt macht gerade wird wandel
durch handel hat nur dazu geführt dass
die noch mächtiger wurden durch den
ganzen handel und jetzt haben sie die
machen mittlerweile den ersten high tech
genozid in der geschichte der welt wo
sie geschirr gesichtserkennung haben und
künstliche intelligenz in die ethnien
der menschen sofort erkennt und eine
datenbank mit 75 verbotenen
verhaltensweisen und dann machen sie das
zur seite und sie verkaufen das an
diktaturen weltweit und jetzt sind wir
in der scheiße weil jetzt hat so viele
diktatoren weltweit haben jetzt einfach
wege um ganze bevölkerungsgruppen
auszurotten auf eine hightech art und
weise und was machen wir wir kaufen
immer noch sachen von china wir machen
da olympia- spiele kaufen unsere
mitten in rom kein werk gearbeitet als
er arbeitet ganz konstant sein plädoyer
um das richtig zu verstehen ist
handelsbeziehungen abbrechen ja also zum
beispiel mit china gerade gesagt so es
gibt vielleicht so eine skala von 1 bis
10 diktatur scheiß mäßig china ist klar
so siehst gewinn von 2
okay das heißt da würdest du sagen das
ist jetzt wie general boykott wäre
angebracht absolut aber dass du das
unterstützen
darum geht es nicht darum ich will ja
genau die grenzen wo sind wir
hier komme ich klar dass hier so nett
jetzt in dem kreis noch etwas glück
bleiben
mir geht es ja genau um diese grautöne
also dass wir uns in vielen punkten
absolut einig sind ist eindeutig klar
aber was machen wir jetzt in zukunft
also china sagst du handelsbeziehungen
abbrechen das ist eine diktatur bis die
löwen müssen wir raus habe ich richtig
verstanden also sagte diese ich zitiere
ich diese diktatur scorer 110
unterstütze ich die karten 12 gehen so
die dimension werden manchmal gesprengt
und er könnte man ganz klar definieren
eben stufe 1 der sanktion ist was ich
irgendwie natürlich das erste
rüstungsgüter stufe 2 eben finanzströme
hinweisstufe 3 und dann diese eskalation
aber
weil dann führt das auch nicht sagen ob
rücken ungeordneten rückzug wo man dann
die
lokalen leute bei denen doch vielleicht
ein bisschen was von dem geld der
internationalen wirtschaft auf dem
lohnkonto gelandet ist dass wir dann
eben nicht dazu dass diese lokalen
bevölkerung einfach über nacht
im sumpf gelassen wird ich muss jetzt
mal zwei toren bist du bei der diktatur
scheißer skala von 1 bis 10 bist du
dabei ich bin dabei mein problem ist
gerade im kontext des konfliktes ob wir
jetzt gerade china in grund und boden
sanktionieren können weil wir gerade in
diesem konflikt in sehr komplex spirale
zwischen russland und ukraine spielt
china eine wichtige rolle und ich glaube
jetzt ist nicht der zeitpunkt um china
zu sanktionieren irgendwie oder
zumindest könnte man ihnen das anderen
aber ich glaube wir müssen jetzt
irgendwie gespräche finden um diesen
konflikt zu beenden weil china und
russland haben wir eine bündnispolitik
in irgendeiner art und weise und da
müssen wir einen weg finden wie wir
damit umgehen können und würdest du
sagen in zukunft mal angenommen das wäre
die allergrößte hoffnung das ist das ist
vor allem für die ukraine natürlich dass
es bald frieden geben könnte an
irgendeiner form wir würden es so
einpacken es würde so passiert würdest
du dann sagen gut jetzt haben wir das
erreicht jetzt sanktionieren der schiene
ja das wäre der nächste schritt ist der
nächste schritt potenzial wir müssten
unser problem ist halt wie melina schon
gesagt hat wir haben ziemlich viel
verpasst wir hätten schon früher härter
reagieren sollen jetzt haben wir den
salat jetzt müssen wir wegen abstufungen
machen und deswegen bin ich rüber
gegangen aber wir können jetzt nicht ein
sanktionen gegen china erwirken können
doch nicht die tube kein grund und boden
funktionieren wir können ja alles mit
allem zusammenhängt auf jeden fall na ja
und weil china noch mal andere nummer
ist nach 1,3 milliarden ist was anderes
als was hat russland jetzt 133 oder soja
also das sind 1 das muss man schon noch
mal sehen ja also ich bin dabei aber das
kann eigentlich nur darauf hinaus laufen
dass man sozusagen globalisierung
irgendwie neu denkt ja wirklich nur
zustimmen oder nicht ich fragte hast
wegen weil du noch da steht und ich will
nur
nicht
fertig jetzt
möglich oder sinnvoll wäre ich china zu
sanktionieren kann ich jetzt nicht
beurteilen ich wundere mich einfach über
diese zeitenwende nachdem ihr
jahrzehntelang auf eine globalisierte
integrierte welt hingearbeitet haben
diese bereitschaft jetzt einfach wieder
unsere blöcke aufzuteilen und die
illusion zu denken ich nenne das eine
illusion dass wenn man wirtschaftliche
beziehungen gehabt dass dann doch noch
ein kultureller wissenschaftlicher stadt
sind das ist dann ja auch weg und wir
haben transnationale probleme die wir
lösen müssen
stichwort klimawandel und wenn starten
sich abschotten in blöcke etc dann wird
die ganze zusammenarbeit wird so viel
schwieriger gemacht also da bin ich war
ja aber ich sehe zu harmonie wie oft ich
hab' ich sehe einfach nicht wie wir in
einer welt die in kassel blöcke
aufgeteilt ist diese wirklich großen
herausforderungen bewältigen soll nur
eine ganz kurze ergänzung mit einem sehr
treffendes beispiel ein freund von mir
gerade in iwano frankiwsk ist in der
ukraine der hat mir da war am anfang
richtig gerührt von diesem großen
solidarität der muss hier stattgefunden
haben und jetzt hat sie gesagt ich habe
kein vertrauen in europa weil das was
wir machen dieses ganze rum reden dieses
ganze paktieren wir jetzt boykottieren
wir jetzt nicht das ist ein zeichen von
wir waren und sind es bis jetzt noch
nicht bereit
real an der seite der ukraine zu stellen
die ukraine in merken dass die ganzen ja
gerade allein nie verstehen okay dass
ein die die einzigen möglichkeiten die
sie haben von uns letztlich noch
waffenlieferungen weil auch über
klosters vor der ja mittlerweile auch
schon längst alles ab die leute fühlen
sich allein gelassen der großteil der
geflüchteten wir sagen jetzt kommen wir
so viele geflüchtete anleihen der
großteil der geflüchteten
binnenflüchtlinge die jetzt im westen
des landes sind und die leute fühlen
sich von uns allein gelassen und mit
jeder minute die wir mit unserem schönen
waren in deutschland im prinzip weiter
diskutieren können sterben dort menschen
sterben dort unsere freunde und werden
weiterhin menschen in belarus gefoltert
weil diese ganzen system mit
zusammenhängen und deswegen geht es mir
darum wir müssen boykottieren und wir
müssen einfach gerade alles tun muss
wieder alles auf den tisch legen damit
wir den menschen dort vor ort real
helfen damit dieser krieg bei ist und da
möchte ich im prinzip einfach nur
daraufhin gehen ist wir müssen die
ukraine in unterstützen und das können
wir nur beim eigentlich müssten wir viel
mehr ukrainische stimme noch gestehen
wenn wir darüber sprechen wir über die
türkei sprechen ich glaube ich glaube
auch und das ist glaube ich auch dass
das eine erkenntnis aus dieser aus dem
versuch einer diskussion über eine
allgemeine orientierungsplan ihren
sachen bei konnten solange der krieg in
der ukraine so weitergeht wie es
weitergeht er gibt das gar nicht so
viele sind es hat mir jetzt mehrfach von
euch auch gehört wer also in dem fall
sind wir uns auch alle einig von anfang
an gewesen vielleicht vielleicht war es
auch einfach ist es auch einfach ein
gescheiterter versuche jetzt in die
zukunft zu denken und darüber
nachzudenken wir gehen jetzt mit erdogan
rum was macht man mit katar was ist mit
china in zukunft weil momentan dieser
konflikt einfach alles überlagert und
deswegen glaube ich auch diese
diskussion vollkommen
nachvollziehbarerweise überlagert nach
dieser sendung habe ich für mich ist
fazit gezogen das habe ich aber auch
schon vorher irgendwie gezogen das ist
nochmal bestätigen da ist wir haben den
ewigen frieden mit dem frieden
verwechselt und der ewige frieden ist
eine illusion gibt es nicht und wir
müssen immer irgendwie uns versuchen zu
wären also die demokratie muss wehrhaft
bleiben und wir müssen verständnis davon
bekommen was in anderen staaten abgeht
das ist meine position für mich als
fazit nach dieser diskussion wäre auch
noch mal festzuhalten autokratien und
diktatur nicht einfach als status quo zu
akzeptieren sondern frühwarnsysteme zu
entwickeln unsere demokratie hier in
deutschland zu stärken aber auch die
demokratischen kräfte in anderen ländern
zu stärken und das sollten wir auch tun
wenn es uns hier gerade wirtschaftlich
vielleicht tut ich muss jetzt gehen das
war schön mit euch wirklich ja ich muss
das erst mal schluss soll ja es ist auch
sehr habe ich genug geredet sonst bin
ich scheiß da ist ghana das ist mord man
sich von heute mitnehme gesagt aber
ziemlich ja aber natürlich ich sage
herzlichen dank für ihre teilnahme ich
weiß es war anstrengend und es war auch
chaotisch aber ich glaube am ende des
tages bleibt doch die ein oder andere
erkenntnis hängen vielen dank dafür
danke schön
dass man wirklich der einst für das war
die besonders zur sendung die wir jemals
hatten eindeutig aber sie spiegelt
vielleicht auch das chaos wieder was
einfach gerade überall herrscht bei
diesem thema und es zeigt auch dass man
in einer situation wo einen so direkten
nachbarschaft bomben fallen und menschen
sterben es vielleicht relativ schwer ist
auf einer abstrakten ebene über die
frage nach konkreten boykotten in der
zukunft zu diskutieren
gleichzeitig hat die diskussion aber
auch gezeigt wir müssen jetzt anfangen
diese fragen zu stellen denn es bleibt
uns ja am ende des tages nichts anderes
übrig als eine haltung zu entwickeln ich
hoffe sehr ihr habt ihr eine oder andere
erkenntnis mit nach hause genommen falls
euch 13 fragen ganz allgemein gefällt
dann könnt ihr hier unseren kanal
abonnieren hier oben gibt es ein
weiteres 13 fragen video und hier gibt
es ein weiteres video zum thema